c'est une loi pour rien c'est une loi
climat de communication qui s'appelle
loi climat mais d'une manière abusive
elle ne répond pas à l'essentiel
notamment la question des forêts n'est
pas dans la loi climat alors c'est un
élément régulateur du climat qui est
essentiel on voit que sur la question de
l'artificialisation des sols
rien n'est prévu que tous les problèmes
qui auraient pu être traités notamment
les économies d'énergie dans le bâtiment
la rénovation thermique tout ça est
repoussée aux calendes grecques donc en
fait de loi climat il ne reste que loi
est plus plus climat en fait on a ici
une de pur affichage qui ne nous
permettra pas de de tenir nos objectifs
climatiques et qui nous permettra
surtout pas de faire face aux pics
climatique de réchauffement que nous
observons ces dernières semaines et aux
événements dramatiques qui sont liés
aujourd'hui il est important de régler
le problème à différents problèmes d'une
part nos émissions de co2 l'urgence on
le voit aujourd'hui en allemagne en
belgique avec les les plus diluvienne
créé par les dom de chaleur peut
disserter sur le sujet mais c'est pas la
question c'est venir un vrai à une
réelle urgence à traiter ce souci-là et
mais réelle urgence à stopper net nos
émissions de gaz carbonique
en fait il aurait fallu faire ce que les
150 citoyens de la convention citoyenne
sur le climat avait avait demandé à
faire c'est à dire qu'il ya eu ces 150
citoyens qui ont travaillé pendant des
mois pour formuler un certain nombre de
propositions ils ont formulé à la fin
cent quarante neuf propositions dans
tous les domaines dans le domaine des
transports dans le domaine de
l'alimentation dans le domaine de la
production de biens dans le dans le
domaine de la rénovation des bâtiments
et si on avait adopté ses 149
propositions là on pourrait dire qu'on
commence à transformer sérieusement la
société mais aujourd'hui on
et très loin de tout ça la plupart de
ces mesures elles ont été encore une
fois soit repoussée aux calendes
grecques soient vidées de leur substance
et aujourd'hui ce n'est pas cette loi
qui va permettre à la france de se
retrouver sur une sur une trajectoire
compatible avec l'accord de paris